life in quarantine I mean are you it's
so nice to finally connect with you by
the way I know I missed you the last
time you were on stage I know I know
I know is that what we're doing good
yes the Norwich Soviets that's right
that's right you came to the musical
episode as well but I don't think you
were shooting that day either yes I had
I have a musical episodes fun I have I
have an interesting little dance and
it's very sexy it's just like dancing
later yeah let's just today I shed a
little bit of Rihanna and Beyonce that
was going through my mind but I was
doing it oh my gosh that is amazing um I
definitely want to come back to that but
I just want to check on you first of all
how are you doing emotionally physically
what's life like right now for you oh my
gosh I'm totally completely absolutely
fine listen I'm one of the privileged
people that you know I have a nice home
in a backyard and I have space and I
work in a profession where it's not 9:00
to 5:00 and I don't love you know week
to week so I acknowledged my privilege
in that sense and I think this is a lot
harder for example my neighbor who's
across the street Cindy and she's a
nurse and she is on the front lines and
she is separating herself from her
husband and their one-year-old been
living at work so in the scheme of
things I mean realistically like I'm
really you know great I mean mm-hmm
the thing that's been frustrating about
this whole situation is more that people
aren't doing their part by staying home
for me so I actually took my son out of
school three three weeks so almost four
weeks ago because I could see this
coming
my husband and I said you know I stay on
top of like world news and I'm from
South Africa and you know South Africa
wasn't impacted by Ebola but Africa is
the continent you know West African
countries were and so I've seen what a
virus can do to a country and a people
and how it can impact day-to-day lives
so we were very proactive very early on
and yeah and I was trying to talk to my
friends my like sort of I think the
thing about this whole situation is
people in America North America Europe
like for the most part in modern day
like hasn't lived through something like
this or experienced something like this
and it's there was a great article in GQ
where the writer I forget her name I
started following her I'm so sorry but
google it it talks about American
individualism and how it's dangerous for
people because you have this idea of
like you know don't tell me what to do
even if it means it's the best thing for
me and everyone else you know I want to
feel free and I'm like come on this is
not the time for any of that you know
this is a community a global community
coming together to support our first
responders and our medical staff and in
each respective country and and the
least we can do I mean we're stuck at
home with Wi-Fi and Instagram and a cell
phone like we're not being cold to war
you know yeah yeah what is kind of the
best part and maybe the most challenging
part about your living situation right
now I mean are you guys getting a ton
more family time in and yeah they're
getting X we're getting a ton of family
time in and especially with my son I
mean he's loving this is great
now he is two and eight months oh my god
yeah so he's really enjoying it I think
it's more a struggle for him because he
misses his friends and he's used to like
that daily kind of preschool stimulation
but you know we got him and trampled
little trampoline and I bought a bunch
of like Dayton's for us to do together
and we have two dogs so he runs around
the backyard with the dog so yeah I mean
it's it's it's great family time at all
so I have time to I'm writing a future
with my writing partner so we've been
focusing on that and then developing
another project which would be a
television show so if some I'm using the
time to attend to
parts of my life if that while you're
filming it's really hard to juggle both
and and then every day my trainer Paolo
machete and I so he trained me for my to
women's health covers and like help me
get back in shape those baby and he also
trains Tom as well as and usually like
10:15 every day and it's for an hour and
it's we're trying to get people to one
like the mental health of this I think
is really important to talk about you
know because like I said I'm in a nice
house with a nice backyard but I feel
for you know those people in New York
for example that are in like 600 square
feet or smaller and it's tough you know
so working out for me is always a good
way just to like get those endorphins
going and and get my mind straight so
how and I wanted to just share it with
you know the fan base and people and I
don't know we're kind of when I work out
I'm really goofy and weird so because it
makes people happy and they get fit at
the same time that's great that's hot
it's the little things right now that
matter you know exactly I do want to
talk to you about Lucifer obviously
because I imagine you guys were kind of
in the homestretch of filming right so
yes we affect production um we were
about halfway through the finale episode
of the season so not ideal but you know
what I am so incredibly proud of my
producers and then my studio one of
others for taking the action that they
did I was you know I was really proud to
- because I was told me to my
entertainment lawyer at the time about
like what the end of what would happen
in the industry who said well you know
Lucifer from what I hear from the
student had become like the model show
in terms of precautions so they had not
just apparel but like mobile hand
washing stations if you where props are
getting wiped they found our handles
stole our trailers like that kind of
stuff but that's that's only gonna take
you so far when you have like a four or
five hundred person crew you know so I
think it was really really tough
decision to sit down but er so I think
is 99% of our show was shot so you know
if they're gonna air the they can still
air the first eight episodes and I
imagine it made I don't know but I
imagine it's probably gonna be around
the same time when we aired the LOC
seasons so many animate made June and
and so we're covered you know but
there's so many shows you um there are
three you know episodes into their
season or pilots who know you know it's
kind of gonna fall away and in that my
heart goes out to you know below the
line oh the crews and those actors who
booked their first pilot you know and
like I remember that feeling
so I yeah it's it's it's really tough
but like I said this is supposed to feel
uncomfortable and you know this time
because I think nothing that was ever
great in history that made a real
positive change from
humanity and the world ever felt great
you know anything people just have to
remember that yeah yeah this is supposed
to feel like an overreaction
yeah it doesn't get the point you know
of Italy for example and I'm glad people
are starting to really take this
seriously I'm glad though that you said
so you still think that we're gonna get
the first half of the season on time I
think so I have no idea what a TI
recession yeah like I don't I mean
eighty yards it's easy to do you have an
engineer in the back of thing you're the
single person that goes in so in that
respect I don't think I think we've
8-yard everything for the first eight I
think I'm pretty sure um but yeah I mean
listen I get flexible so completely new
territory I mean they're sink crazy
probably viewership they're like oh yeah
what do we do like how do we you know
navigate this so and I think they also
know that then they they are hoping you
know by having all this content
available so I'm hoping that we can
stick to our same title in line and keep
fans happy and maybe give them some
escapism from a little bit you know yeah
absolutely like we talked about earlier
I have talked a lot of grassed about
what's going on in season five what can
you tell us about mazes journey like
where is she at when things pick back up
oh my gosh
so what do you guys like though I know I
mean she's heartbroken
you know as we've all been there and and
I think she knows she throws herself
into work and so you see her with Chloe
a lot because I think their stories are
kind of marrying each other and they're
leaning into each other as girlfriends
do and and as you guys all know it does
eventually come back and there's all
kinds of drama
yeah but I will say for me as an artist
and as the person you know as the
actresses played this character for five
years this is much for my best work as
an artist I think like they really you
know are some fantastic storyline and
themes and ideas to explore there's even
a great there's great scenes with DeeDee
which I think a lot of that girl I
thought they made a deal it sort of
you're not sure like funny of the ex
hookups or friends or yeah there's a
really good scene with DB actually
badness you where by the way TV plays
amenadiel yeah mr.brother and and if you
if you've been a fan from season 1 um
you'll know that exact same because it's
a great recall to the first season and
then I do incredible work with Kevin to
my gosh he's so good this year and I'm
music like as soon as I say it is super
fun so yeah I do some sexy dancing and
that and I sing with Tom in the noir
episodes so do it that great yeah yes so
I got to really flicks and do things
with her with magic in that I haven't
done before you know and I think to
having the freedom for the writers to
write a show for Netflix you know fully
knowing because last year it was great
but we were like with Fox canceled fair
enough so it was like rejigged you know
and this now I feel is like the pure
Netflix version of our show and it's so
damn good I'm so excited to see it I'm
so excited you mentioned a lot of scenes
with DB and callbacks from season one so
do things turn romantic for them
no no I think I'm scared to say no but
okay but I think I think no I think that
I think what you what you will
appreciate is at the end there that is
you know you have the angel and the
demon which by default they're supposed
to be on opposing sides right and it
seems but both of those characters have
evolved and had to buy your force
explore their humanity and so in the act
you see this blossoming of like like a
new relationship between these two and
it's it's it's really beautiful I was
really looking for the closure with
those two you know as yeah actress yeah
yeah what about her friendship with
Lucifer I mean I know it starts off
rocky but then it comes back so how do
you feel about their their friendship
this season I think this thing to
remember about those two is they are
forever connected forever like as I have
experienced so much and there's a really
fun scene which is kind of heartbreaking
to but fun for the fans who are the
purists we wanted to see like those to
the the maze and Lucifer characters
maybe like the old school versions of
thing but they have to go through that
journey me too what's heartbreaking
about it I can tell you give us
something we we do know that we're gonna
meet God finally this season
so does maze get to interact with God
and if so in what absolutely absolutely
there's a really Dennis Haysbert is just
a gorgeous actor and
really is really great work at Chinese -
Oh characters I mean I can say that she
goes to him and asks him for something
huge oh wow yeah what what brings God
sort of into the fold this season like
why is finally showing up I don't know
they're kids kids are acting the fool on
earth he's like time to check y'all
you've given us so many good good teases
is there like a maze moment that you're
really excited for people to get to
watch in the first town yeah yeah not
she deal she deals with one of her big
family like you know how people can
carry around like like hurt from a from
a family experience like you know and
she has she is confronted but having to
deal with something that is the ultimate
betrayal that I honest I I can't go into
too much detail but and it's really
challenging for her and she will carry
that throughout this year like
throughout the season like 2d like
almost toward the end and it even that
hurt even though it's present-day is
tied into the nori like the noir episode
is really masculine story Wow okay I did
about that I know is there anything in
the romance department lined up for me
as I feel like people like her with Eve
you know I mean I think she's at the end
of this season like she makes a decision
that is the best for her but but she
goes through that break up hurt trying
other things she then has to confront
the eggs and by the end of it she makes
a decision that's the absolute best
things
her and and and and the character moving
forward yeah when I talked to your other
cast mates they all talked about the
finale in how it's gonna end and how
fans are gonna feel I'm curious what
your reaction is to that and now there's
of course well we'll get to that in a
second I'll let you answer that um it's
it's like I think the general feeling
for people will be throughout this
season it is like a constant almost
angst like the next minutes I need a man
okay I just need to make sure that
that's fine oh this happened like you
know like it's it and it definitely is
like the complete like explosion of all
those things that we experienced for the
season but it is like we're all in it
and there are a lot of scenes with all
of us together which i think is really
nice because you rarely get to see like
the full seven of us you know yeah
exactly it's always like you know the
Lisa's police detectives are there and
then Lucifer is there with his brother
maizes here with Linda or you know
whoever so yeah it's it's pretty it's
huge
it seems there there there was there was
one scene it was gonna take like five
days to shoot and you guys had a shot
not one yet no so that's something that
was you know part of the work that we
had halfway through that it so yeah are
you guys all communicating I know you
guys are all such good friends are you
on text message right now where you stay
oh my god they're texting me as I'm
talking on this like chain give us a
glimpse into it um lord knows me well I
know and you know people are we're
having a laugh I mean our kids are
pretty words are pretty funny but also
you know people are being informative
about like what's happening
and III think it's you know I think we
all just are just like happy to to not
to be in the position you know that were
and we're just grateful you know that we
finished most of our season run them and
that we have this time now but um yeah
it's sort of like it's crazy it's just
so uncertain
you know with everything but yeah
they're on they're doing good like this
is my jam good to see the world
yeah I know you don't know the answer to
this but there are reports that maybe
season five won't be the the end would
you like to see the story continue
correct
sure you know I I love I love my job and
and I do feel like it would be fun to
explore especially considering where we
and all from the season five on that
being said to you know I I feel like our
show is peaking and I don't want it to I
want to stay in on that like wow you
know like that was amazing so sure I
would like to and I know they're rumors
but listen I I go by one really
important role this business unless I am
standing in line for Kate earring or in
that makeup chair I don't know does it
end on a bit of a cliffhanger like
wouldn't make sense to continue totally
ah huge I cannot wait to watch this I'm
so excited yes you guys don't even know
it's kind of fans are gonna be and I and
I will say too I do want to my most
brutal fights and I had a lot of input
and choreography and the you know
and Jason England wrote the episode and
Belgium under they directed the episode
she's also our show and her and it's
it's one of the means is it's the most
brutal fight like you're gonna see
you're gonna see Magic Kingdom help so
she got really in bringing the heat Oh
this season it's like my body like I was
working out this morning I'm like listen
guys I have your shoulder engine on that
plate
it's from all my fighting and punching
with my right hand set oh yeah old
injuries quarantine and if we're to if
we do get a selfie amazing well I hope
you guys get season six
I can't wait for season five before I
let you go we do want to do a little
rapid fire with you if that's okay sure
okay so you're go to quarantine snacks
and food usually a banana in the morning
cuz I don't really have big meals
kombucha and I do this like vegan like a
little unlike protein shake I know I'm
boring I'm not like a huge foodie I mean
you said popcorn and I was like yeah I
actually found this amazing service a
flavored popcorn
we're closed legged yes way to go okay
what shows are you binging right now hey
Jess okay so I just finished so tricky
with this two and a half year old at
home you know by the end of the day
shots actually all the teachers
preschool teachers we do this with like
18 kids in the classroom because I don't
know how y'all do it you deserve a
million dollars a week but right now it
is
I just finished dirty money
like I love documentaries so dirty money
what else doing watch i watch the other
guys or a little bit of a loss I do love
that movie
I've been catching up on on Watchmen and
what's the other thing I just watched oh
I finally finished position yeah okay
okay good so good anything on your list
of things to watch next
are you planning that out yet yes
killing Eve and I 1917 I haven't seen it
my those are my two medians like right
now you know yeah I have a list any
hobbies that you've taken up well in
quarantine
um disinfecting my house and more
organized I am just you know little
Martha Stewart back here Mary condo I
should say but cooking I get to cook
again because you know with my hours I
don't um so my cousin's really enjoying
that because he he loves my cooking yeah
I think we're all doing really getting
to cook alright and then the last one is
what's your current live in outfit like
are you sweats all day no okay let me
show you because if you guys don't have
this it is from yep do you know that
brand
I don't but okay so Lunia does like
washable silk this sounds so bougie I'm
so sorry I don't want to sound like it
a hold right now but I'm Lunia they do
like washable silk PJs
lounge where and so this is a little
combo set of there's oh it's so cute
yeah lepers so that's literally yeah all
day every day I'm nice I'm working out
and I love it
amazing good uh it's very cute and then
do you just have a message to your fans
right now I mean I know we're trying
we're all trying to stay positive right
now anything that you want to tell them
like a message of hope maybe perhaps
yeah I want to say that you know just
reiterating what I what I said earlier
like this is this is supposed to feel
like an overreaction because we don't
want it to get to the point where as
we're seeing major cities are being shut
down and hundreds of people are tasting
positive so the way we lower that curve
is for us to stay home and do our pot
and if we can you know put politics
aside although it's very hot I
understand because there are people who
are actively responsible for where we're
at right now
and and and do our part by staying home
and you know using the time to connect
to to the family or if you want to get
in shape work out or if you've been
meaning to start that veggie garden like
me that's my plan you know out of out of
this you will come out hopefully healthy
and and so well many other Americans and
then just support support your first
responders and support your you know
I've been trying to buy gift cards to
small businesses online that I go to to
help help them with that I have some
neighbors that are elderly I you know I
left them notes and destructed the door
going if you need anything please walk
over drop it at my door
you know so it's like well a mystic
I know it doesn't feel like we're
connected and and and I hope this is
what if America actually gets out of
this is you're not you know it's not us
in them like if this virus is showing
its shown us anything we are literally
all connected yeah I love that
well thank you so much for your time I
really do just as magical as I knew that
you would be and probably when all this
passes we'll be back on set and we'll
we'll get to bring this ways yes all
right
state no give your son a big hug I will
thank you guys
wash your hands stay stiff they Madigan
[Music]